[Music]
hey on today's show we're gonna be
talking about adult themes so if you've
got little
ears in the room take cotton swabs and
shove them way down deep there or
send them outside tell them to go be
human beings get some cuts and scrapes
and play in the yard
we're gonna be talking about social
media and cheating
and marriage we're going to be talking
about a young man whose parents may be
using him for money
and we're going to be talking about
somebody struggling through a sexless
marriage
and what to do next stay tuned
yo yo good folks i'm john and this is
the dr john deloney show
the show for you about you where we walk
alongside one another talking about
relationships relational iq
mental health parenting falling in love
sometimes we talk about people who don't
know that hallway traffic rules are the
same as the highway
so if you're gonna text and walk down a
highway
oh nope you're going to not walk down a
highway but if you're going to text and
walk down a hallway
walk on the right side or you're going
to get some donuts and coffee in your
hair
i don't know why that's so hard walk on
this side or that side just like you
drive your car right
so whatever if you're looking for
honesty in a world where truth doesn't
exist anymore
if you want a first or second opinion if
you want to learn how to walk down a
hallway
or learn how to talk which i'm not doing
very well this morning i'm here to walk
with you so give me a call at 1
844
that's 1-844-693-3291
again you can email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
people are emailing all over the world
the the support has been
off the charts it's been extraordinary
overwhelming and beautiful so thank you
so much
email ask john ramseysolutions.com
leave your number how we can get in
touch with you let me know what's going
on in your heart and your
mind and in your relationships and kelly
will reach out and see if we can get you
on the show
just a quick update the the show
launched a few weeks ago
and the response like i said has just
been second to none could never have
imagined
this from a guy that listens to like
three podcasts
um and that's only on occasion this has
been overwhelming it's been a dream come
true
big shout out to kelly daniel james
child zach bennett in this squad who is
putting this thing together behind the
scenes
i'm grateful for them thank you all and
i'm just grateful for you the listener
who is
keeps tuning in the youtube folks who
keep watching
thank you so much as we're trying to
figure out how to be humans again with
one another
so let's go to the phones let's start
with let's go with
beth in bristol virginia beth how in the
world are you this morning
i'm good how are you good good good how
can i help
well i've been married for 12 years we
have two small children
and i found out a few months ago that my
husband has been
messaging other women on facebook and
a couple of them i've seen were not you
know just kind of benign but there was
one
where he is talking to this girl and
it sounded like i couldn't see the whole
conversation because i think he had
deleted some of it but
um sounded like they may have known each
other before
but um he proceeds to tell her and i'll
kind of be
pg about it but proceed to tell her how
attractive he thinks she is
and that's all of the you know the
message i've seen
um but i've been kind of struggling with
it you know trying to
figure out is this like cheating or am i
kind of overreacting about it
or and how i should approach him about
it so
uh beth what did you
say to him how did he respond when you
talk to him about it well i haven't
talked to him about it yet
i said it kind of threw me for a loop
and
um i'm just you know i just don't really
know
what to say to him about it so pay me a
picture
i guess paint me a picture of your
marriage how is it how have things been
uh you know they've been pretty well um
you said you said that you said that
with hesitancy that's been pretty well
like give me pay me a picture
well i mean you know we've um when we
got married
um we had a pregnancy that
um i went to pre-term labor and lost the
baby
and so again we've been through a lot
you know several deaths in the family
and
and on and on but um i mean we get along
you know pretty well we don't really
argue very much
um you said you have young kids tell me
about you
tell me about your small kids how old
are they we have a 10 year old and a
uh soon to be three-year-old okay so
you're in the same boat as
as me and my wife all right so y'all are
flat on in it right
yeah my little boy was kind of a
surprise
yes surprise yes but it's a good
surprise on most days right yeah yeah he
just gets across
yeah so cutting through all of the this
is and that's
no actually before we cut through
anything i've got to know who have you
talked to
about this nobody
so you've just sat on this for a few
weeks all by yourself
yeah yeah how did you stumble on these
messages
well um he's kind of guarded about his
phone
so i mean i don't go on it a whole lot
but he uh
i left it over there and it deemed or
something and i was just kind of curious
you know who it was um and it was
a message from this random person i was
like i don't even know this person
you know why they messaged my husband so
i looked at that and then i seen the
other messages
so did something in your heart and mind
tip you off to something's
not right that the the boat you two or
drift
next to each other on they're starting
to drift apart or is this just you
happen to grab the phone
um well like i said you know he's kind
of guarded about it
about his phone he rarely kind of leaves
it just laying around
when i after i had our son
something similar kind of happened he
said it was
nothing but he was on instagram
and i don't even know how i came across
it now but um
it was like he had posted a comment on
somebody else's picture and i guess
that's how i've seen it
but he had sent me something in spanish
and it was like you know you're as
beautiful as a rose or something like
that
so something very specific he sent that
to me
like previously that day and another
message and then i was on instagram just
looking around and
i said he had posted that on some other
girls picture
yikes i confronted him yeah i confronted
him about that then
and he's like no that you know that was
just an error or something and
you know we kind of had a little
discussion about it but so has he ever
chewed on you before has he ever cheated
on you because i know of
you know i don't have any physical
evidence that you know he's ever
cheated on me physical evidence because
now we're a detective agency right
yeah that's right um so the ultimate
question here is this
do you feel betrayed well yeah i mean
i just yes it's really upset me
and but you know it's it's kind of like
you know it's a graphic it's kind of
like pornography i mean
i've i've mentioned because he has i
know he has
watched porn before and i mean i've told
him that i don't like it
and yadda yadda and he he says he's
stopped or whatever
but uh i've talked to other people about
it they're like well porn's no big deal
i'm like is this more like kind of a
porn issue well so that's where i'm
asking you
is the only voice that matters right now
and i'm going to walk you through a
couple of things here but the only voice
that matters to me right now is you
and do you feel like this is you've been
betrayed
yeah okay so in my opinion then it's
cheating
if you think it's cheating then for your
marriage and your values and your
context it's cheating
um and so you notice the questions i
asked you which is who have you talked
to about this because
you're going to get all kinds of
different if you go to the magazines or
the googles or your friends are going to
get all kinds of different well you
should just think this or this is no big
deal or this is a big deal
and that can be really painful because
in your heart you're thinking no it is a
big deal right
yeah so that's kind of what i was
wanting to get an opinion about is this
is this a big deal or should i be
concerned about it here
here's my thoughts on um cheating
and these are hard and these are
probably counter cultural i took these
directly from the who's the the
the matriarch of relationship language
in the modern world and that's ester
perel and she
writes a lot on infidelity she writes a
lot on
marriage relationships and how couples
work through things
and as i was going through her her
information
one thing stood out clear to me and it
was it was a heart stop moment for me
because it made me have to look in a
mirror too and my guess is is that 99.8
percent of people listening to this and
watching this are going to have the same
moment
but as far as she's concerned as far as
i'm concerned
cheating infidelity is a secret
and that's the full sentence there it's
a secret
and so if we let we live in this culture
where the
the definition of cheating keeps
expanding right it's just getting bigger
and bigger and the
access and the ability and is a quick
text
is a flirty bump into somebody in a
hallway is
going to grab lunch and have coffee with
with female co-workers
or is it you have feelings for somebody
at work they're a fun person to flirt
with but you're never going to cheat
physically right and so um at the end of
the day
i think you know if someone or something
is cheating
if it involves secrets if it if you
can't tell the other person
in your the other partner and so i had
to be honest with myself and think man
how many times over the years have i
cheated then under that same definition
as people are driving now thinking well
don't i get my own private life for
people watching the youtube like well
i get my own private here's the thing
man a relationship a marriage means you
become one
and so when your right arm starts hiding
things from your left arm that's the
very definition of
infidelity right and most of us think of
cheating
as i didn't sleep with anybody i didn't
put this
there i didn't kiss anybody i didn't
hold their hand right
and so i love that esther perel says
cheating is a much
bigger picture it's this idea of
desire it's this idea of arrows right
and a secret becomes a brick of fire in
your soul
and so i don't know anything about your
relationship beth i know anything about
your husband i don't even think
anything about that right what i can
tell you is
just because somebody is chatting with
somebody else doesn't mean that your
marriage is broken
it doesn't mean that he doesn't love you
right often those kind of things are
about
him um there's a great uh guy his name
is jack morin
i i wrote it down here the erotic
equation
is attraction plus obstacles equals
excitement
or as ester perel says we are most
intensely excited when you're a little
off balance
a little uncertain or poised on the
perilous edge between
ecstasy and disaster
and so often cheating isn't about the
person you're leaving
it's about leaving you the person you've
become
and often in relationships when without
thinking about it you got two young kids
you've been together for a decade or
more
you've been together for two years or
more and it's not what you thought it
was or life became
life you want to leave the dead
undesirable
frustrated abused lonely person that you
are and so my question for you beth is
this
paint me a picture of you sitting down
to talk to him do you want to go to war
do you want to blow things up do you
want to know what's wrong with you
like does this make you question am i
still beautiful does he
still desire me or does this make you
want to
fight for him right
well i don't know about this
unfortunately i don't know about the
third one so much because
you know i kind of see this as he's the
one going out and
doing this you know it's not like some
girl messaged him and was like oh i
think you're really attractive and he
was like well i married
that or whatever you know it's him
telling this other girl that you know
how attractive he thought
she was or whatever um but i mean it
does make me angry um
you know in what way angry for how dare
somebody be in the heart of my husband
or angry how dare he did this and he's
he's throwing everything we've got away
probably a little bit of both okay
and you know it does make you wonder was
is this the first time he's done this is
is there other times that you know that
i just don't know about that he's done
this
and it also could be that the person on
the other end of this phone
on the other end of this phone is a 72
year old co-worker
who he says you're beautiful as
oh get out probably not but here's the
deal
you don't know and you don't know
because you have a secret now from him
which is that you know this thing and
that you're secretly playing detective
behind closed doors and you're secretly
having all of these imaginary
conversations with him you're secretly
judging him watching him like a hawk
and i'm not saying you're out of bounds
on those things but what i'm saying is
you're
living in secret too yeah that's true
and so under my definition under esther
perel's definition of infidelity
of cheating it's this idea of holding a
secret
right and so you're not stepping out of
the relationship
erotically or physically with somebody
else
but you're stepping out of the
relationship as this 30
000 foot hawk judge right
having fantasy conversations with
yourself with him
you've probably even imagined running
into this other woman and how you're
gonna
do whatever you know what i mean you
start having this world and suddenly
this guy laying down in bed with you has
no idea that his wife is literally on
fire from the inside out
because you're carrying hot bricks too
right
no so can i ask you a couple of hard
hard questions
they're going to make me not a fan
people on the internets are not going to
like that i'm asking you these questions
um and i'm asking you this not because
you're the woman
if you were a guy calling me with the
exact same question i'd be asking these
exact same questions
okay this has nothing to do i think
women have taken heat for
millennia for it's your job to make sure
he
stays fired up and at home and blah blah
whatever dude
so i'm not asking this because you're
the woman okay am i asking you this
because you're the woman
no okay good all right you're listening
okay great so
um do you wake up every day
or most every day with a single minded
mission to make your
husband feel desired
that he is sexy that he is a vulnerable
that he is safe
and that he is loved
oh well probably not it's a yes or no
probably not no adjectives no no no
as far as you feel comfortable and safe
do you try the
wacky intimate things that he's into or
do you
value yourself and your sleep
and how you eat and how you exercise not
to have a hot body
that whole thing's been perverted is
ridiculous not that
but so that you can be whole when you
enter his space
when you enter into his world
um i kind of lost you on that one
okay do you take do you love yourself
enough to be whole
so that when you okay yeah all right
that's what i'm asking
i mean i probably could do a better job
well it's not a judgment thing it's just
a thing to think
right do you look at a screen more than
you look at his eyes
here lately probably yeah okay so here's
all i'm getting at
not that anybody causes anybody to do
anything i'm talking about an ecosystem
or a context
i'm talking about people who cheat often
don't hate the person that they cheated
on they don't
want to not be in relationship with they
just want to feel alive
they want to feel desired they want to
feel like somebody
sees them and hears them and loves them
they want to feel that
little bit of this is a disaster this
could be dangerous
and when couples decide together that
we're going to create that world inside
of our
tight boundaried up relationship
man you can get a forest fire inside of
a jar
if couples do it right and it's it
starts with one another saying i'm going
to create a context i'm going to create
as emily nagotsky says
i'm going to create a world where it is
all ons here and no offs
i'm going to create a world where it is
all accelerator
and very few breaks and we're going to
honor and love one another in this
context
and that still is not going to guarantee
that somebody doesn't cheat
because the price of love is hurt the
price of love is
risk and love is hard and love is scary
and so that's why direction secret free
here's some things i love here's some
things i don't love
here are some things that would make my
my
world be less full of offs and more full
of awns
and man there is just places where eros
desire
love takes off and then man you're
talking about a whole new planet for
relationship development for growth
for intimacy when suddenly you're the
one getting those texts
you're the only one getting those texts
you're leaving notes for him
he's working really hard in the gym not
just to have a hot body but because he
knows
man when i work out my brain is clear my
heart is clear
i do look pretty good my testosterone's
running
my body's working and i can fully be
present with our kids
i can help with energy after dinner
i can help go to the store and i can
clear the deck so the romance party
becomes a
gasoline-fueled fire
but at the end of the day you don't know
any of that beth because you haven't sat
down and had a conversation
cheating and infidelity start with
secrets
they start with secrets every couple
defines those differently
every couple has different values
different things that are okay in one
relationship and not okay in another
relationship
but they start with secrets and so
you're gonna have to sit down have a
conversation
please don't have this conversation when
you're fired up when you're exhausted
on the back end of another fight set up
a breakfast
set up a lunch set up a dinner where you
go out and you say hey i love you
we've been together 12 years we've got
two kids we're exhausted
i feel this drifting apart i found a
message i went to grab your phone
and if he throws a temper tantrum and
says i'm telling you not to look at my
phone then he's a child and a baby and
you can stop the conversation and say
you're not ready to have this
conversation we're going to have it but
you're not ready
and we're going to come back and we're
going to do this again because i love
you and i love this relationship
but don't give up on your relationship
for a series of texts
just because there's infidelity just
because there is
oh i got a lot of secrets i have a lot
of
things that i probably haven't talked
about with my partner
don't don't throw out everything you
mentioned right you mentioned
we've been through deaths together we've
been through a dis like
heart-wrenching loss of a baby a
miscarriage
we've been through all these things
together he's a good dad he's a good man
he's looking for excitement or maybe
he's a jerk man whatever
start with a conversation beth thank you
so much for the call thanks for letting
me spend a little bit extra time on this
particular issue we get a lot of
conversations a lot of questions about
cheating
infidelity what does that look like
we're in a whole new world
check the show notes for some of the
books that i recommended
some of the authors here esther perel
emily nagotsky
and then we'll go from there all right
let's go to the let's go back to the
phones let's go to
cody in somerville south carolina
brother cody how are we doing
i'm doing great excellent brother how
can i help
so i am 17. um about to go to college
and i feel that my
family is just trying to drain me of
money
for everything so you feel like they're
draining you of money one is a feeling
one is a thought and one is an action so
tell me what's making you feel this way
i will then it's all three okay
excellent asked me for so much money
and i told him that i'm trying to go to
college like i need money for college i
need money for an apartment
and a whole plethora of things and
neither one of my parents work and have
worked for
six to seven years how did they get by
man
um i have another brother and he
works all the time and he just fell in
that sinkhole
with with them do they have any
long-term disabilities or they just
choose to not work
my mother chooses not to work but my
father he got
um he got hurt and he's waiting for
disability but
disability has apparently taken five
years
wow so i can hear almost a hint of
disgust in your voice is that fair
uh yeah that's very sorry okay so i i
didn't
at the beginning i i didn't hear you
quite right you say you're 17
i'm 19. oh you're 19. so do you still
live at home
um yeah i still live with them okay but
i'm trying to get out of that
environment because i know that
environment is just it's horrendous
so when do you move out
that's why i'm here i wanted to ask
about when i should have
when or how i should move out and
about what tomorrow
why are you still there i can't just get
a place immediately i can't i don't have
enough income where are you working
right now man
i am working at um spinx gas station
i make on average almost all the time
about
1600 amounts
get another job get two more jobs
get three more jobs what's holding you
back
um nothing really i mean the only thing
that's really holding me from the
apartment
is probably the income and it also
i feel that it would be better to you
know have a roommate to help with the
bills cut them in half
i feel that would be the best way all
right i'm going to give you some hard
love here cody because you called me is
that cool
just a second ago i asked you did your
parents have any long-term disabilities
and you told me my mom doesn't she just
doesn't work
my dad does but evidently social
security or evidently disability takes
five years to come in
and in that sentence i heard the disgust
and the disdain and the frustration with
your old man
i heard the your disbelief
of always having an excuse my dad's
always got a reason why he's not doing a
thing
he's just saying well the check's going
to come and there's going to be this
other thing
and so here's my here's the deal cody i
heard that in you
if you really wanted your parents to
stop taking your money you would have
moved out you're 19 years old you're an
adult
you're old enough to be sent to war
you're old enough to buy smokes you're
an adult
if you want out of the situation cody
get out of the situation
start tomorrow go get a second job a
third job a fourth job work like crazy
talk to your brother and say dude we've
gotta stop floating mom and dad they've
gotta
start working they don't have any reason
to go to work right now
because money just magically appears and
they're robbing you of your future
but you're always going to have an
excuse man you've got a
model in front of you of people who lay
down excuse after excuse after excuse
not to say that your old man's not hurt
man long-term disability sucks it takes
it's debilitating it takes your
soul from you it takes your dignity from
you i'm not saying that he doesn't have
some some serious challenges
what i'm saying is i'm already hearing
you cody
well you know i kind of need to wait for
a roommate and then
dude just go do it man just go do it
just
go do it
tomorrow go get another job it's it's
it's in the middle of a month right now
by the middle of next month you should
have an apartment lined up you should
have a deposit saved up
go work like crazy go get it done
brother and yeah move out man
and then go to college go to a local
community college there in somerville
go find a local community college here
in south carolina get started on your
classes
go to a local trade school and make some
smoking money being a mechanic
being an air conditioned guy go to go to
school
at a local community college and get on
whatever it is you're going to be
getting on
but the day you stop putting these
barriers in front of yourself stop
inventing excuses well i need this just
go brother run
run you've got permission and freedom
and don't be a punk
to your parents they love you even if
they don't know how to show it you take
the high road treat them with dignity
treat them with
respect tell them at this time next
month i'm moving out
and they're gonna say we've heard that
before cody and then you put together
your plan and you live it and you work
it out and go do it
okay after you move out cody i want you
to call me back i want you to call me
back let me know how you feel
if you feel free if you feel open if you
feel scared i want you to give me a
shout back let me know how things
are going all right cody you can do this
just go do it
just go do it all right let's go take
one more call let's go to valentina in
floor
fort lauderdale valentina what is up how
are we doing
hi dr john thank you for taking my call
i'm a big fan
thank you so much i'm a fan of yours how
can i help
thanks well um i live in a sexist
marriage
for over nine years and i don't know
what to do um
i'm i've gained weight i'm a little
depressed
i i don't know what to do so sexless
marriage up it's been sequels for nine
years or y'all been married for nine
years and it's evolved into this
we we've been there for nine years and
since we got married
it's his libido or his desire has
decreased
he has been tested his testosterone is
low
then we just recently tested and it's
high now it's normal
but his desire isn't there okay and
it's hard for a woman to have um
a higher desire or i guess maybe
i don't know if i'm the only woman that
has this in america
but my husband has like zero desires we
have
intimacy once every two months once
every
month once every three months it's very
difficult
yeah so you posed several questions
there so number one no
actually it's it's a big secret and it's
a secret that weighs on the hearts of
women
millions of women across the country it
weighs in the hearts and backs of
millions of men
across the country is this idea of
expected libido
guys are the the cultural narrative is
that guys are just these sex crave
lunatics that are always wanting to do
it and that's all they ever think about
and wives are prepped for this well you
know he's just gonna and then they get
to this marriage with a set of
mixed-matched
expectations and then things just go
awry
so out of just sheer curiosity what are
the things you've tried over the last
nine years
well um i've tried role-playing um
i've bought very sexy lingerie
um even though i'm not into porn
and he was very important when we were
dating and then
suddenly it just he took off all the
porn
out of that out of the house and we were
dating our sex life was awesome
when we were dating and then i've even
suggested if you want if that stimulates
you
if you want to watch porn we can try
what they're doing and
it just i don't know we've even tried to
set up a schedule you know to see
if you know such days we can role play
and you know we'll meet me at a bar
we'll go to a hotel nothing
and so yeah you've gotten to the point
where you're trying to force feed it in
there
um what yeah or just you've gotten to a
point where you're trying to make it
happen what does he say
he's very ashamed and
late we had a huge fight um
a couple days ago i'm sorry i'm getting
emotional no of course
um he just said that i have to deal with
it
and it's difficult yeah absolutely
we've i've you know we are we've been
trying to have a baby but like i told
him we need to try
if we're trying to have a baby we
haven't been able to conceive in five
years but
we both need to do our part
right so i i just feel lost i feel very
lonely
yeah i feel very alone abandoned
emotionally i've never
ever cheated on my husband i've never
wanted to do that and i don't
want to do that ever i'm a christian
woman
i love my husband i don't know what to
do
and i sank into a little bit of
depression i feel
i gained 20 pounds because of it
i don't know what to do so number one i
want to applaud you for reaching out and
being vulnerable okay
thank you thank you for honoring me with
your trust there okay
thank you the second thing is is trite
as this
sounds this is more than likely not a
valentina issue okay
and i want you to i mean high praise to
you for giving it all you had
and for really trying to work through if
it was situational based if it was
desire based if it was
i'll do fantasy based whatever it
happens to be
it sounds like you've put in the effort
and the love
and the care and you've tried to really
do your part there and i
and i i salute you okay i want you to
hear that
um the other side of you just got to
deal with it that's not an acceptable
answer to me
and so were this clear this call is hard
for me
is i can't talk to him right
and so my guess is well i don't even
want to speculate there's so much
that leads to low libido there is so
much that leads to
um the potential for sexless marriages
and it can be
everything from like you said shame
that's
all it's relational based all the way
back from childhood
there could be this moment when you
became girlfriend you became wife and
he's got a picture of
wife which is really just an elevated
mother and guys don't like to sleep with
their mothers and so it could be this
big psychological quagmire
it could be something not testosterone
related but something
other more medically biological related
it could be that he is finding himself
attracted to
um men and not women it could be a
hundred thousand different things
and we've discussed that you know are
you homosexual do you like men
um he says no he's not attracted to men
um he's not an uh um a drug addict
at all right he's not into drugs he's
not cheating i've looked
and nothing is just but so here's the
deal here's the deal listen listen
listen this is gonna be hard to hear but
he is not
a puzzle to be solved okay
and he's not a problem to be fixed
he's a person to be with and what i'm
guessing is the amount of shame he is
walking through the world worth
right now is extraordinary
and people who are feeling shame think
of a backpack full of cinder blocks
and people who are carrying that around
say things that they don't mean
they get frustrated at the world just
because their knees hurt just taking
simple steps
and so statements like you just got to
deal with it that's not a statement of
somebody who loves and cares and desires
somebody that's a statement of somebody
who's hurting
okay yeah and he's had an erection
problem
so he has ed right he does have that but
and the root of so much of that can be
psychological and physical and
trauma it can be so much have you guys
gone to see a counselor has he going to
see somebody
psychologically we have um
the first year of the marriage because
from the day that we got married we had
intimacy that day and then five months
later
we did it and i kept you know
um pursuing him and nothing so i did go
to a counselor by myself
at first he did go for one or two
sessions but then he didn't want to
he was too ashamed to talk there you go
to a woman
about the situation about the fact that
he can't get an erection
and it's difficult for men than for
women that's what he said
well that's just again it's not that's
just guys him trying to
package this in a way that he can wake
up every morning because the the
the shame is pretty overwhelming um okay
so he's got to
this is not a you know i think so this
is a have to
he has to go see somebody and talk about
the things that are
wound up in his heart and soul and
here's the thing
you can't make him do that the more you
try to control and pressure and push
that's more bricks and more rocks of
shame and the backpack that he's already
fallen over from right what you can do
is you can go see somebody
to deal with your frustration and your
heartache
and you can model for him what
somebody's standing a little bit taller
and a little bit taller and a little bit
taller looks like
okay okay i want to i'm telling you this
but i'm also telling anybody watching
this anybody listening to this
life is too short to live in a sexless
marriage life is too short to live with
bad sex with people who don't talk to
one another people who don't communicate
people put up for a decade with things
that they don't like they're not
comfortable with
things that they wish their partner was
doing just because they they
carry these secrets around they don't
have hard conversations with one another
and so we will go two years five years
10 years 20 years
without having hard conversations and
and suddenly man we find ourselves
sitting on a couch again two inches
apart from one another
and 2 000 miles away we're on different
planets
right and life is too short for that i'm
speaking in the choir here i know that
the only person that's gonna be hard to
hear the only person
valentina that you can deal with right
now the only person that you can
you can you can change
is you you can control your thoughts and
your actions
and the things that he says the things
that he doesn't respond to
a decade of trying to become his muse
is worn your soul out it's heavy and
it's exhausting
and i want you to walk with a
professional counselor for a season
to make sure that that doesn't become
your shame that you're carrying
that somehow your value is diminished
because you couldn't
accomplish this thing in somebody else
you have more value than that
you've got more integrity than that and
you are worth more than that
and i want you to model for him what
getting well looks like what being
whole looks like i'm not concerned the
fact that he's got libido issues that
happens
i'm concerned that he doesn't care
enough about you
to go to the ends of the earth to try to
be whole and well
in men listening to this men watching
this there is not an excuse
to not be honest with a doctor there is
not an excuse
to not go see a counselor and say help
me i am
drowning the person that i love more
than anything else in the world
because of crap that i'm carrying that
happened to me when i was a kid there's
no shame in not being able
to put down your own bricks guys i'm
telling you from a dude that struggled
with it it's
hard it is hard but when we commit to
somebody for the rest of their life and
we tell them that we love them
we have an obligation to go to the ends
of the earth
the ends of the earth that means going
to have an awkward check at the doctor
that means sitting down with a therapist
male or female i don't care
and saying here's what happened to me
when i was a kid here's what i see when
i look in the mirror
here's what a wife
meant to me growing up and all of a
sudden i can't be
i was wildly in love passionately in
love while dating
recklessly erotic when we were dating
and
now that we're married it's i lost it um
the whole world transmission the whole
thing changed i'm terrified of being a
dad whatever the thing is
the combination of medical psychological
guys go
see somebody and this is not just about
sex this is about depression this is
about anxiety this is about guys who
are worried about being good parents i
don't care what your issue is guys get
over it
the world needs us to step up and start
feeling the world needs us to step up
and start being vulnerable
the world needs us to step up and start
being with people
not over them connected to them not in
charge of them
and so i'm i'm i'm i'm begging you guys
go talk to somebody that will hear you
and that will love you
all right valentina thank you so so much
for this call
um i want to thank all the callers today
just remarkable
beth um and cody and valentina thank you
so much
for everybody writing in everybody
listening everybody watching thank you
for walking on this journey with us
we are all of us are real people we're
all on the same team
we're all just trying to figure out what
the next wobbly crooked stack
is going to look like and we all need
each other all right so as we wrap up
the show
whoo man i don't often do this i don't
often do this but i'm gonna go with the
greatest song ever written
i i man sometimes i bring my my jv game
here
the greatest song ever written by the
greatest rock band
of all time i'm putting a stick in the
ground i'm making a declaration ladies
and gentlemen
here it is off their 1996 record
white heat white light white trash
social distortions
greatest song ever written mike ness in
company
rattled off this gem it's called i was
wrong
he wrote when i was young i was so full
of fear
i hid behind anger and i held back the
tears
it was me against the world and i was
sure that i would win but the world
fought back and punished me for my sins
well i felt so alone and so insecure but
i blamed you instead
and made sure i was heard they tried to
warn me of my evil ways
but i couldn't hear what they had to say
here's the magic words gentlemen
i was wrong self-destructions got me
again
i was wrong i was fighting everybody i
was fighting
everything but the only one i hurt was
me
i was wrong
if we could all say the words i was
wrong followed up with i'm sorry
what a world this would be this is a dr
john deloney show